[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
reebok seeds
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying for the
mangoes forcefully affected the american
people
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right welcome everybody what a
special day it is the day of the first
2022 david pakman show
chess tournament
it is going to be i think a really great
tournament and i'm glad that you're here
this is open to everybody i'm going to
give you all of the information about
how to sign up this is free it starts in
9 minutes and 16 seconds
and it'll be on chess.com so very very
simply if you want to play
just go to david these links are in the
twitch description and the youtube
description they're not in the facebook
description but it's all very easy
um you go to davidpakman.com
chess and you just join our chess club
on chess.com that's free
then you will see in
the
um
club that it says like event starting in
eight minutes and then you can register
for the event there's currently 99
people registered and we are standing by
for more
um
we have all sorts of uh we have people
ranked all the way from let's see
all the way starting at
332
from 332 all the way up to over 2200 we
currently have three people
rated a 2000 and higher a few people
that are going to be playing in today's
tournament include international master
eric rosen david pakman arena let's see
what he's saying
oh we're muted hold on
you're welcome fist bub or fastbub
or festbub
[Music]
okay so i'm gonna join this tournament
yeah please eric join the tournament my
god
uh there he is okay so eric just joined
uh grandmaster benjamin feingold said
he's going to play but the weird thing
is
he's offline right now which concerns me
a little bit also jessie february is
going to play she is saying
davidpakmanarena on chess.com so let's
check in there
[Music]
okay so it's the musical portion for the
time being but it is all happening and
happening very very quickly
uh mr kusha chess twitch is now the
top-rated player
in the tournament and it is all
happening all happening we will have
super chats
up on the screen the whole tournament
i have one political element for you
guys today we're going to be looking at
this deeply deeply deeply deeply
on tomorrow's show
this was dr fauci bringing receipts and
holding up a picture of rand paul
fundraising off of attacks on fouchy
look at this i guess you could say well
that's the way it goes i can take the
hit
well it it makes a difference because as
some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago on
december 21st
a person was arrested who was on their
way from sacramento to washington dc
at a speed stop in iowa right and they
asked the police asked him where he was
going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci right and they found in
his car an ar-15 and multiple magazines
of
ammunition because he thinks that maybe
i'm killing people so i ask myself
why would senator want to do this great
question so go to
rand paul website uh oh and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here oh my god five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gain so you have politically attacked
your colleagues and then comes the
interruption from vile and disgusting
rand paul and we're going to cover we're
going to cover that deeply deeply deeply
deeply tomorrow but it is vile rand paul
is just gross
thank you to nug wrangler for re-upping
his twitch prime sub for 28 months also
also saying thanks to c shelton for
gifting five subs and we continue to see
huge subscription dumps big massive
dumps happening on our website i want to
say thanks to don sullivan as well as
well as austin hoke
and
glenn
shukster for signing up on my website we
are still banned for 90 days from
facebook monetization i did a whole rant
about it yesterday um we have the code f
facebook f facebook which you can use um
and it is
it is really something it is really
something so glad to see
that that uh all continues to happen but
today is a day for chess welcome it is
the first 2022 chess tournament of the
year and by that i mentioned it twice by
saying the year right 2022. um you can
join the tournament by going to
davidpakman.com
chess join our chess club and then join
today's event you will see it there it
starts in four minutes we want as many
people playing as possible we've got
some great people playing uh let's see
what's happening on some of the streams
of these people
uh
wait i know the solution
okay
here we go coca-cola gambit
okay so eric rosen warming up there
uh we ben feingold is still missing
we did lose a couple people levy rosman
reached out and said he's he's
he didn't play good chess today so he
was gonna bail for the day ben as far as
i knew was still going to play
jesse february is playing
and uh awaiting the start
of uh he might come here and see you
watching him oh is she watching my
stream watching her that's awkward so it
starts in three minutes
[Music]
three minutes
okay
um all right so everybody uh pl please
participate please participate we
currently have uh six players at 2000 or
above
and we have so many players ranked
everywhere in between this will be a 3-2
game you can just play you don't have to
stream go to davidpakman.com
chess players ranked as low as 234
all the way up to 2601
a still alive says do you know how to do
the on passant move in chess yes i do
yes i do that is something i've been
looking at that
really strongly
really strongly and we're going to
continue looking at it
thanks to zur sir zakaria
for the twitch prime
subscription let's see what else we've
got oh right i should switch over to
chess on twitch category for today
that's a good idea
that's done i want to say thanks to joe
cross for signing up on my website with
the coupon code f
facebook
we have two minutes until the start of
the tournament you can join even after
it starts but why not join right now
why not join right now at
davidpakman.com
slash chess
167 players registered so far
we have room for up to 2000 that's the
maximum that can play
um
and we are getting dangerously close
down to the last 90 seconds before we
start
open to everybody davidpakman.com
chess
daniel says ben feingold's participation
is up in the air sir your wife is up in
the air yeah we don't know what's going
on with ben
uh still showing it ben may be no call
no showing which would be
really really sad
that would be extremely sad
but
these things sometimes happen these
things sometimes happen
um if you're just joining
it is uh it is chest day it is indeed
chest day not chest day
but chess day
uh you can sign up this is free this is
just a good time all i'm offering is a
good time i'm not selling anything
uh
an additional player above two thousand
a lot of people joining up here we're
down to the last 50 seconds but you can
keep you just keep joining joining
joining davidpakman.com chess
john balduck has just signed up on my
website with the coupon code f facebook
very much appreciate that
and mahaffey taffy has just made a
twitch prime subscription we are 30
seconds 30 seconds from the start of the
tournament
uh with nearly 200 players 191 to be
specific
um
and again it's it's free
and anyone can play i see continued
confusion anyone can play
davidpakman.com chess we are at 199
players
and 200 players what a beautiful number
you can join after it starts you can
join anytime you can quit anytime
it really is open to everybody
and here we go
first game against jd philly
waiting for j.d philly to make the first
move and we are off and running ladies
and gentlemen
i'm not going to overthink too many
moves here early
just going to play smooth anybody can
join anybody can join no restrictions
let's go here
uh
wow already getting extremely intense
extremely aggressive
extremely aggressive game
i should make the chess board bigger
yeah let me see what i can do maybe in
between games
it's sort of like a uh
it's a verbal inkblot test uh uh game
here okay so if i take there that's not
good
i think i might
i think i actually want to defend that
i think i'll pre-move that just in case
and we are off yes davidpakman.com chess
if you would like to join
uh
hmm
might go right into the queen trade
oh that's not good because i lose the
piece yeah that's not that that was a
disastrous move
uh okay let's go oh wow and i don't even
know how i can defend everything
that was a disastrous move
and i can't even defend here because of
this
wow very very bad move
complete and total blunder
yeah i think now i have to
maybe attack here no i can't do that wow
going bad quick
going bad really really quick losing
everything
losing everything
and now i think i think that's lost
there i think it's just this
double it's just blunders everywhere
guys it's just for fun okay everybody
remember it's for fun
uh
all right now i don't even know
am i considered tilted already
uh
i'll just keep pushing here
get out of the way of the check
man
this is probably lost but
it's like should i even resign but
hmm
maybe i just keep pushing forward and
see what happens
yeah it's not even really clear what the
right move here is
i don't think i've got it that's for
sure
oh wait here
we're gonna play it we'll we'll play it
out
yep
i think i might just go and hide the
king
right i can't even do that all right
we're resigning
next game let's move on
terrible start absolutely terrible start
here we go let's get it back
yeah the first pancake is never really
good
playing against calors rage here from
germany
anybody know who's ahead
see if ben is streaming
no looks like ben is bailing that's
really too bad
eric's right in there
wow
hey i won due to an abandoned game i'll
take anything at this point in time all
right here we go again speed mcwin
from the united states let's try a
similar
opening and see what we get
what's the definition of insanity doing
the same thing
and expecting different results
let's see what we can get here
hmm
so i usually take in this situation
and then
here
and then usually here
i'll take wins by abandonment all day
guys all day
i have no problem with that at all
uh okay
what about this does this work
it doesn't really work now
oh man
okay take this
hmm
is this a good idea
actually i think i prefer this
let's see what speed mcquinn
decides to do
right
uh
i think i'm going here
people wondering what's going on it's a
chess tournament we're running it we've
got a bunch of people playing you can
join at
davidpakman.com chess it is totally free
totally free to play
completely and totally free
um
[Music]
i really need to figure out what my next
move here would be
do i want to align the rook with the
queen
or maybe just get the queen in somewhere
here i want to make sure i don't lose
that
i think here
very much unclear to me
obviously
um okay
maybe here
i hope many of you are playing i know i
know many some of you are
you've gotta you i see people saying
they can't join the tournament
you've gotta join the chess club first
to then join the tournament okay
expected that i don't i'm not inclined
to really
do too much about that i might double up
here
speed mcqueen really putting in a quite
a game here
could trade here
i think i i think that's to my advantage
to do this
is there some kind of nasty fork
that's what i'm seeing
hmm
okay
so i just moved back
i don't think there's an obvious issue
davidpakman.com chess guys i see
continued uh people asking how to join
davidpakman.com chess really easy
um
also the link to the tournament is in
the twitch description and the youtube
description you can find it very very
easily
still a possibility of getting two pawns
here in exchange for
either of these pieces don't really know
about that
um maybe i want to take away
that square
but then now then then there's nothing
else defending here
i think i might go here
i'm not uh let's see
thinking this
hmm
hopefully other people's games are going
better than mine let's just say that
uh okay
i do think i like this idea
and i think i would capture with the
rook
don't not not loving this right here is
the only thing i guess i'd have to be
willing oh no you know what i'm going to
do this
because then if here then i attack with
that
then queen would probably go there to
think about that
that's something i have to look at very
strongly very very strongly wow a lot of
people signing up for memberships
appreciate that okay expected that
uh
so now i think
i think here
because it takes now it's defended
all right let's see if we can make the
chessboard bigger
uh okay so i guess it's a trade i'm just
gonna oh no i don't do i don't really
want to take that trade actually
because then this and then i've got a
problem actually but it might be okay
you know what i think i'm gonna do it
and then here
we're going to work
on making the chess board bigger
i did not account for that
i think now
okay that there's a little bit bigger
now we're running low on time
let's see this is quite a chain here uh
let's see what we can make happen
i think i might just start moving my
king in
keep it on white squares maybe
at a certain point this is probably
going to move
i think i'm gonna keep going
this this looks bad for me it looks very
very bad yeah
um
i think i don't even take that i think i
go here
and then just trade here if necessary
okay
i think here
i think i'm trading here and then here
so i think i'm going here
we've got some possibilities here
i'm gonna keep working my way
down expect that
this is getting pretty wild guys
hmm
i think we're going here try to lock in
the bishop
and then moving over
moving over
oh boy
this is quite a game
i think i might try to start collecting
pawns on the back here if i can
i think maybe we go with a check
oh no
that is that is brutal
oh there it is there it is wow
all right let's see who's winning so far
bunch of people with nine were up to
nearly 300 players 300 players wow
join at davidpakman.com
chess let's keep going let's keep going
we're going to keep going
i love people saying that there was an
engine move that was obviously the best
one it's like well yeah okay
oh hold on a second
even during this there's people that i
have to ban
uh
ban a lot of ban hammers being dropped
here geez it's kind of sad to be totally
honest by the way obviously tons of
people are cheating i know that it
always happens in every tournament that
we run
they typically get found out after the
fact
um it's sort of sad
it's sort of sad
but um
yeah it it happens to the best of us it
really does
have this position a number of times
this is usually the way i play it
uh okay that's interesting i think
usually here
yeah cheating in a chat it is really
really sad
really really sad
i'm going to castle away
can't join anymore that's weird as far
as i think i'm going to take on passant
here
uh oh that we had a possib really
possible move there but okay let's go
here
um
you should be able to join
you really should
uh
do i just take this pawn
cause i'll try it
hmm
[Music]
here
is this is this reasonable
oh now wait a second wait a second
maybe here
let me think about this
there's got to be something here this is
there's got to be a winning possibility
here
so then it's got to be this right
discovered check on the king while
attacking the queen
i think
and then i take the queen right
uh
we go check
here now here
oh interesting
check
pond
uh
do i go check here
i'm not actually sure the best move here
huh
has to go over
oh wait a second
can i win the rook this way
here
there it is all right finally got a
legitimate win
um okay so i'm being told you can't join
anymore let me see about that
um
no there's 291 players people are
continuing to join people are continuing
to join
so i don't i don't think there's any i
put that people can continue to join and
every every game that i play there's
more people
so it does seem as though you can
continue to join we just had 15 people
join
uh okay
something different here let's see what
we got playing against
koenigsbauer chen
let's see what we can do here
okay now do i want to take that i think
i don't
think i don't
i think this is the move i want to play
ah well that may have been the reason to
take it i mean i guess i just go back
save the piece
and then take here actually opportunity
to whoops
yeah i can take here
and get the night back out and then i
think i continue with the night
i mean i guess i take the
it looks like a free pond
then it takes here i'm taking this way
yup
would be great to open this up somehow
this is apparently the rui lopez berlin
defense
i who knew
yeah so let's see if i take here
i think i go for it
and then now i've got a double attack
right
oh i missed that that's the easy defense
missed it
um
maybe here and we'll see what happens
with onpassant
we will see
because this is the idea that i have
it's a pretty it's a pretty low level
idea i'm not gonna lie but
my opponent at least now has to figure
out how to deal with it
okay
so i i just take the rook right is there
any reason not to take the rook
coming here wouldn't be a problem here
here here i i think i just take the rook
yeah
uh okay and then maybe i attack both
pieces here
is this an idea oh no
oh well actually that's not a problem
that's okay
it's not a big deal
i think can the queen defend both not
really no
no that would be just losing
i don't think the queen can defend both
okay uh so i take it
whoops oh no that was didn't move yet
um okay
i think i just
i think i just take
i mean no no
um
is it this if takes here
and then it takes i back i have back
rank i think let's try it it feels
intuitively right
but it may not be
um okay
okay
i think i try here and then maybe get
the other rook in
so let's see if takes and then takes and
then i go here
then basically it's this
i don't know what to do with that
uh
i guess i'm gonna try it
so let's go here
okay then i take this one
there's gotta be this has to be winnable
right
i think i'm going to come over here
i'm giving up what am i giving up if the
queen moves i've got another pawn
but now
this is a possibility
so maybe first another check
and then here
and then if moves out of the way i can
take this one depending on where the
yeah so
here
and then here
now what is the mate opportunity here
here
that may have been a mistake
well i guess this is theoretically made
in one
make him defend
i mean okay yeah but then here
and then this is still mate in one
you know
i guess this is the defense right here
yep oh
here
now i'm actually unsure
wow this is uh
i'm actually unsure here
hmm
i think i did mess it up
i wonder if there's some opportunity to
get the queen to this square
and if i use the rook to take away these
now because then the queen still comes
in
do i just start moving pawns
let's try here
does this help me i'm not actually sure
okay let's now
oh there's i think i just made a very
bad blunder
see if my opponent sees it
oh opponent didn't see it
let's try this
oof that's not good
that's not good at all
i think i've got to go here i'm going to
lose the pawn
guys this is giga cringe
let's just start moving pawns i think
there's got to be some way to win this
here
oh there it is oh my god this checkmate
oh it's checkmate oh my god that was
wild
okay let's see
uh oh my god is this producer pat in
first place look at that at 696 producer
pat is in first place somehow
uh eric rosen's playing ben feingold
seems to have bailed jesse february's
playing it was like accidental checkmate
that was insane
let's keep going let's keep going i
thought i was going to need more uh i
thought i was gonna need more more moves
than that
okay let's keep going
oh and i missed how many people are in
the tournament we'll check at the next
break davidpakman.com
chess
uh no we're not gonna chat right now
i'm all set with chat thank you
let's keep going
usually i like don't worry about that
and i just bring oh wait but no that
doesn't work here
uh oh is this a problem
this could be a problem
let's go here
did i screw this up
or did or did they just box themselves
in
a lot of people in the chat saying
they're winning
uh okay let's get some pieces out
this this really has me worried here
i think i should also open this up
keep going here and then it takes here
and attack the rook
the hell just happened oh i just gave up
oh beautiful just gave up a piece no big
deal
this isn't going great
obama elements of bathrooms
um i think i take this
this is this feels bad right here
especially with the pond right there
uh
i think we're gonna get this out of the
way
i kind of want to do this and this yeah
this is my idea right now
i think defend
still thinking this
it would be great if this got moved for
later
because i would love to end up with the
queen here
king this way
and take this rook
but right now this knight is defending
it
so it would be great if my opponent
ended up getting that out of the way i'm
not even going to worry about that right
now i'm just going to go here and see if
i can execute that
hmm
do i want to trade there i don't think i
want to trade there
i think i just go
um that's actually that's tough i don't
know what to do here
i go here and then trade there
davidpakman.com chess is where to go
you've got to first join the chess club
once you join the club
oh my god hold on a second
i've gotta ban people again sorry
there we go
um
i think i take here and then
actually i think i go here more
interesting
we just had a very very strong ban yeah
extremely strong
um all right
do i trade there i mean i'm behind is
the issue so i don't know that i really
want to be trading i almost don't have a
choice i think i have to actually
there's no safe square it's just a
question of where do i trade
uh
if only i had a bishop
if only i had a bishop
hmm
i think here may be an idea
and i would just you know trade here if
necessary i guess
oh thanks to the bedizzle for signing up
via twitch prime very much appreciate
that number 14. also have people to
thank on my website okay the trade
happened as expected
now let's see
do i take here
then here
take oh my god i just gave away my queen
all right
resign i i just i just gave away my
queen for no reason whatsoever okay
producer pat knocked out of first place
um
some of these people
guaranteed are cheating guaranteed are
cheating
uh 326 players now let's keep going
let's keep going all right let's see if
we can get back into it
oof there's a lot of really weird stuff
happening in the chat
like bizarre
let's go with the ponziani again and see
what that gets us
it went okay the first time this is a
higher ranked player than me
a lot of people confused about why the
higher ranked people aren't winning
there's enough players where people are
mostly playing against opponents of
their own skill level so it comes down
to how quickly are you playing
unfortunately it just it is what it is
it is what it is
okay i've dealt with this before right
now
the pawn is pinned
i've dealt with this before i think i
know how to do it
this happens often in the panziani
oh man we gotta ban the same person
again
okay
uh
[Music]
maybe here
it's going to be this right and i think
i just move out of the way yeah
i think this
hm this might have been a bad idea
think looking at it again this might
have been a very very bad idea
um
seems impossible to defend this right
so
if this i still lose this
why will my game auto resign oh my god
that's weird what the hell was that
i just got a message so so this is
obviously not good
but i just got a message it was about to
auto resign that's insane
by the way how are the calzones yeah
um
line is the if i go here is the queen
trapped can't go here can't go here
can't go here can't go here can't go
here can't go here can't go here
oh no it has to go here okay so this
oh that almost traps the queen wow but
it doesn't it doesn't that's the issue
it doesn't actually
um
i think i'm going to defend here then i
think the queen might be trapped later
oh no but i'm losing a piece
right
right
well that's no good i think i'll just
castle away
and then take here if i need to that was
a miss that was definitely a mistake
yep so now i take here
this is now exposed though
hmm
do i pin the knight
maybe so
kind of thinking does this check get me
anything
let's
let's see what happens here
okay
so now
if i take oh no no no no no oh that
would that be very very bad very bad uh
let me think about this
is there a winning idea here
i don't know that there is
this still can't move though so this is
mate in one right
because of the pin
a lot of banning going on it's sad
uh okay is this is this maiden one
no because of this
okay let me think about that
what can i do with that is the question
right
um so now there's no more pin
which is kind of a problem because now
the queen's attacked
i think maybe here
not not sure i love like this i'm very
very far down i realize that
can i go here
i am really unsure about this
oh wait what about this check
does this do anything oh now the rook is
down hold on a second let me think about
that
the rook has to come down
oh no it doesn't okay
but now i can take this
that helps me i think
and then maybe over here
and then the rook has to move and maybe
there's mate there is there is this
maybe something
i think there may be something here
i think my next move has to be to go
after the rook on e8
ah and there's the escape square okay
let's try that
rook will have to move i think i go here
oh he's just going um
i think i take it
now hold on a second i don't really want
to lose that do i
oh wait no i go like this and i defend
now i'm defending
there it is and then i take the queen
okay
and then now i've just got to figure out
here
and then here
uh here
i'm just taking everything
oh no that's back rank needs space
get out of the way there
here
here
here
here
and then i've got
oh there it is it's checkmate
didn't even realize that it was
checkmate all right
340 people now playing
340.
you can join at davidpakman.com
chess i want to say thank you to brian
morrow as i go to my next game
rosa rodriguez iris friedman and mark
dane for signing up at joinpakman.com
with the coupon code f
facebook so much is happening here let's
keep going we're gonna play a little bit
of a different opening now
just just trying something a little
different
i think generally
now i don't remember what i usually play
here not that what i usually play is
good
but uh you know okay here i take i know
that
and then i move back
all right let's get settled in here
hmm
so if i take and then takes
take take i don't know if that
i'm gonna try to trade a whole bunch of
stuff let's just see what happens here
let's see what happens
okay i expected that
so now
wait a second what's the right order
is it here
no this doesn't even work i don't think
oh man now i'm committed to it
no maybe it does work
i guess it depends on what my opponent
plays oh because there's also this right
so now
do i go here first
obviously there's this
let me think about that
right okay so
now i do this
because then this is still under attack
no it's not because of the queen oh but
if the queen moves i would have mate
right
oh that's almost i should almost just
give it away and see if he falls for it
right because if i if i take this
and then the queen takes
is that mate
that would be mate right
let's see what that that actually oh
okay
i think i'm just gonna do it right
because if
i don't think he can take
can't can't take right now the thing is
now i need to protect
let me think about this
uh okay so he realized it you realized
it um
now what is the question
if i go here i'm attacking both of these
pieces that's something
but then he can take
exposing that defense that's not good
either that's not good either
okay so let me think about that again
takes now i can't go here
huh
yeah i'm not sure
i think oh i think i'm doing this i
don't know what i'm doing here i don't
know what i'm doing here
i've i'm the idea is just to defend this
another way
uh okay
so now
this is under attack but do i care
uh
man this is this is getting complicated
i think i'm defending that oof
i thought i had a good position now i'm
not so sure and i'm down on time i'm
gonna try to double up here
um
now
oh wait now is the time for this move i
think
now is the time i think for this move
this would be very bad but now this is
under attack
can the queen defend both
yes
here oh but he didn't do it
hold on a second so now what happens
it's this right it's gotta be that
ah look at that
an actual win
that's a legitimate win folks wow i
think that's my best game
uh here's eric coming up very very
strongly
let's keep going
wow
wow
i will take that all day
i will take that all day all right next
game let's continue
okay i usually take and then attack this
way defend with the bishop
ah okay now this this is where i've
gotten into this trick before where this
becomes a problem i think this is the
right move here
then bring the knight out
i think this i've had this before and i
often screw it up
[Applause]
maybe just target
that pawn for no real reason i don't
know maybe get to defend
ah okay
i think i castle this way
i have no idea how to play these
positions i really don't
do i go for no i can't even sack i don't
think it works
could just randomly take this but that's
an easy way to get trapped you don't
want to do that
uh i kind of like the idea of getting
the queen here
i think i keep pushing here
oh night was defending that pawn yeah
fair point
do i take there i don't think so
i might just line up the rook here with
the queen for now not really sure
hmm
now i'm very unsure what to do
am i okay losing this or that i kind of
am to be honest
yeah i don't want to take because then
the pawn can double attack i think i'm
better off maybe just getting this out
of the way
um
but can't go there oh because then i
could potentially expose the queen i
need some breathing room for the queen i
think
so i'm actually going to get out of the
way this way
this could get complicated pretty quick
and i'm like way down on time way down
on time oh i'm playing someone who's 2
000 of course i'm going to lose of
course i'm going to lose
um
let's go here because it also opens this
up
oh no that is just brutal
that is brutal um
i don't even want to go here i guess
here and then
here to avoid undefending this
yeah this is bad
this is bad
this is very very bad
i think this is the only move
how am i even matched up with someone
with twice my rating like how is that
even possible
i guess i just take
it's bonkers is what it is that's
exactly right
uh
just go here
i think this
just trading everything
it's all a trade
then the problem is this will become
undefended
is this just mate here
i think it is
i'll just trade everything
who even knows
what a brutal game
all right we're done let's keep going
that was bad but listen twice my rating
you know what i mean what can i do
delaying the inevitable i know i know
up to
358 players now
what a what a tournament
uh okay
let's do something a little different
here let's do petrov's defense now
that's black right it's black's defense
okay
and there's some issue i believe with
taking this pawn in that previous
situation
i think we may uh
we may fianchetto here
i get the issue here i would trade a
rook for both these pieces right now
i think this
i've been messing around with h3 and h4
historically
now
here
kind of interested in this square for
the night potentially
i might try it just to see what the
reaction is for my opponent
okay
i think i just get out of the way
oh that was that's a problem that's a
real real problem
um
i think here i'm kind of defending
everything right
this is an historic game
i mean i'm defending this and attacking
that so that's that's something to look
at
uh
seems like this would be a safe square
and this would be a safe square those
are the really the only safe squares for
the for the rook right
all right my opponent's thinking that's
at least something
oh wow memberships keep dumping in here
hold on a second
thanks to francis denmark for the new
membership darren smith
ron oil
virginia fountain
joe addy
and gregory van meckelen
putting us at 24.
um
okay so now
i don't want to undefend this square
i think now
maybe this right is is the uh
is the bishop getting trapped here
i think the bishop might be getting
trapped
oh hold on a second
maybe not
oh but now that's not an issue anymore
maybe here just to keep it close
and now i take the
oh my god
oh my god
all right i guess i go and try to attack
both
i'm an idiot
it was pinned
there's no way this holds together for
my opponent right
trying to think about it
if the bishop goes anywhere i take the
rook
if the okay i think i take the rook
i think i just moved back
wait no i've got a
i should attack the knight in case oh
and i can't go there oh my god the queen
this is bad this is actually not so good
all right i think i have to go here
if takes then takes right that does work
what the hell's going on so now the rook
is under attack
i think i just go here
i think
this is getting sort of ugly
yeah that was a very very bad move
and then now i take here now i've got
both under attack
hmm
do i block
is blocking an idea
this is not good
i gotta get my other pieces in here oh
this is this is very bad
yikes
this is this is a disaster
i don't even know what i'm do sir i
don't even know what i'm doing
maybe i just try to get more pieces in i
mean is this is this just mate
no it's not but
i don't even know that i can move there
i think maybe i go here
this might be the only idea
yeah this um
oh wait a second that's a free piece
hmm that was weird it was like perfect
play and then all of a sudden not
very strange right
something about that was odd
uh i think i'll go here
okay take and then take again
i am very low on time i'm aware of that
so here
oh that's not good okay i go here
i think i just try to get the king as
close as i can
no
that was a mistake
all right now we gotta just start
pushing pawns
let's see if i can properly get a pawn
break here
think this is it
hmm
oh no what a disaster
and that's the game that is the game
folks wow
wow wow wow i think there should be a
review of that game done something about
that guys i'm not going to accept
challenges obviously obviously i'm in
the middle of a tournament all right
let's see uh what else is going on i
want to say thanks to barbara soudis
for signing up on my website your new
member number 25. let's take a look at
how eric's tournament is going
a lot happening over here
okay so now
[Music]
nothing i'm too concerned about
all right so eric's on fire
ben just never made it ben said he was
gonna play and he just never showed up
and then uh jesse february
i think is playing although is this oh
these are ads okay all right that's
what's going on all right let's continue
anthony d bernardo currently winning all
of these games will be run through a
cheating filter after the tournament and
you can go to davidpakman.com
chess
to join yourself if you would like to if
you would like to
okay i usually take here on the center
game
i actually take both and then deal with
the problems later
uh usually i play here
ah
i get myself into trouble with these
very very early
and it's just sort of the fun of it
[Laughter]
okay uh
let's see what else we've got
i think maybe we do a pin here
and then try to attack this way
let's see what we got
okay
um
i think
here maybe no that's not a good idea
uh that was probably a mistake
just as a goof i could try to threaten
mate in one see what happens see if then
there it's gone
okay
um
just go here
the knight is no longer pinned of course
and could go here now and attack my
queen
and there it is as expected
i'm kind of interested in this square
is this possible
oof that's not so good
all right i guess i gotta move out of
the way
i think i'm going to take here no that's
a bad idea because then the queen will
ultimately be
able to attack here that's not good
this is pretty bad this is pretty bad
um
and this square still potentially is a
problem
yikes this this is very very bad
i think i go here
actually no i can't go there
i go back here
okay here
i'm taking this for now
okay
i think maybe
this is very very dubious for me
actually there is something interesting
here
if he doesn't see it
hmm
we've got another ban over on youtube no
problem
we can handle that uh okay so
does see it i think i'm taking
just taking
yep
um
that's quite complicated
i mean right now everything is
i think everything's defended
see if i go right after the queen
just to see
how my opponent reacts also this rook is
doing nothing here i've got to get it
somewhere where it can do something
and in fact let's try to do that now
while keeping it away from the bishop
and then i will take here
and i think i'm gonna line it up with
the queen just see what happens
let's start pushing this pawn let's see
what we can make happen here
just a lot happening on the back rank
here
okay attacking the queen
i want to avoid getting forked
but i think here
time becoming a factor time is becoming
a factor
oh no
what a disaster all right gotta move
takes the queen but i take back
that was a disaster
keep pushing up
that was bad
i got forked brutally brutally
uh i think now i just am trying to keep
my pieces
that was a very very aggressive fork
yeah
i think uh
this is quite bad
this is quite bad
hey i'm still in it guys it's possible
and there is checkmate not a good
showing not a good showing all right out
of nowhere d mill chess has now taken
the lead
producer pat has fallen to eighth place
um
eric rosen is in second place with a
number of wins in a row
okay
let's keep going here
quite a tournament
376 players now in
big thank you to jim bogues
mark costco
abner santos
and june stevenson for the tw for the
website memberships very much appreciate
that
all right here we go new game
clearing the decks
oh and thank you to um
thanks to blueberry babe for signing up
on twitch and gifting a sub
very much appreciate that
uh okay
let's go here
it's the vienna game that we are now
playing
you know what i'm gonna take it
and then here
here
okay
okay
uh
[Music]
let's go here
thinking of maybe fiance on the bishop
very very stuck right now
creates an opportunity
maybe just here just to get it out as
quickly as possible
maybe here
oh thanks jesse uh thanks for playing
yeah i know it's very late in south
africa really appreciate you playing
hope yours went better than mine
the the night is not hanging guys
because if the night is taken i take the
queen i appreciate the support in chat
but i would love
for my opponent thomas to take the
knight because it means i can take the
queen
uh okay
i'm gonna start pushing on this side
maybe
okay so now i actually do have to do now
now the knight is hanging
and i think i've got a fork here right
is this a for no oh my god no no no no
no all right i think i'm just going to
take here
and then i'm going to go back
and what i'd like to do is try to open
up
here
i think i'm not going to do anything
about that right now
here i i think the king's okay i don't i
don't think this is an immediate threat
hmm now i'm actually kind of unsure
got to be careful of this
okay
i'm gonna slowly push up
okay i'm not super worried about this
pawn but i should create some kind of
danger somewhere if i can
uh
i think i'm gonna go here
i'm okay losing that pawn right now i'm
trying to get you know more going over
on this side
yep
now
do i attack the queen just to get it get
the queen moving around
um okay
i think here
oh my god pawn checkmate
what a disaster
what a disaster
uh man that is that is not so good
that is not good
i do want to say thanks to paul george
for signing up on my website thank you
paul appreciate that
um
let's ban a few different people
there is a there's a lot of oh my god
it's shocking that during a chess stream
we're banning this many this many people
we're down to the last 15 minutes of the
tournament
everybody is invited to play everybody's
invited to play come on in let's take it
and take it
and here i had a game like this already
interestingly enough
uh wow this is the i we had a game
exactly like this which i think i won
makes me wonder how many of these
players are using engines quite frankly
um okay a couple other people that i
need to ban
all right let's just trade the queens
let's do it
we've got some power moves here
davidpakman.com
chess is the place
uh let's keep let's keep pushing forward
here
sometimes i'm not really sure what to do
with this bishop in these positions
see what else we've got
i think i might move the knight here
i'm risking doubling my uh
pawns but i don't really have a choice
if i move this then i lose the rook
which would not be very good
let's see what star tropic can come up
with here
thanks to my x1 for the twitch prime
subscription very much appreciate that
number 33 today
okay
would i want to take this and then would
take back here
and then what is the question i think
i'm going to do this
actually i kind of prefer now
i don't have to double my pawns
if i go here and attack the rook just
moves over and then i've got to defend
the rook
got this
let's try here
just to draw this out
because then that's a real problem
see if he falls for it
did not fall for it okay
uh this square is a problem now but we
can i think deal with that
hmm maybe move over here
are there more people we need to be
banning we'll just keep banning people
all night
uh yep let's see another ban
uh okay
i think i'm interested in getting the
rook there
let's get an additional defender going
here
i think i'm taking it
oh this is uh
even with this i've got the same thing
right
i think
because if here then here and then same
thing
i believe i believe is there any other
way oh no no no this is the move right
that's the
move
oh but he didn't do it oh okay all right
well i will definitely take it
um and i think i've got to move out of
the way
and then
here
can't take here obviously oh actually
that's that's a good move
that would be a real oh but that
huh
i think i can do this
and then i think i take here
and then
there we go oh oh my god that was a i
did not even that was a miss click
but i guess i'll just trade here if
necessary that was a total miss clip
click
then the knight would have to move
um
now if i go here no oh no no i don't
want to do that
i don't want to do it let's go over here
yeah if you're going to miss click it's
something right i don't even know
i don't really know what the
right way to go here is
just start maybe pushing pawns forward
maybe a mistake we'll go here
did not i'll move over here
gotta avoid these pieces from getting
forked i think i'm not gonna do anything
there and i'm gonna keep pushing for now
so now i will take
and now we'll start pushing up
i think i keep going
uh okay
think now which way do i go maybe i just
i just try to actually go after the
knight
so here's a double attack
there we go
take there
and then i should be able to if i go
here
and then here
do i let that go for now i think i do
and there is the resignation there is
the resignation wow
wow what a uh
what a game
what a game eric rosen has jumped out to
a lead i think i'm gonna actually watch
eric now
because he is running away with it i
would only get in one or one more game
maybe let's see what eric's got going on
he may be ready to win this thing
it's interesting
thanks to jeffrey smith peters
as well as alex emmick
and austin sullins for signing up on my
website 97 looks passive but we're
watching uh the current leader of the
tournament
eric rosen
we're trading down a bit further here
uh there's only nine minutes left but
you can go to davidpakman.com
if you want dramatically changes the
structure let's see what eric's up to
probably threatening something like
queen g6
and a shout out to eric's dad by the way
i know eric's dad was looking at playing
in the tournament he listens to the
podcast if eric's dad is out there big
shout out and then play queen g6
i'm calculating um a funny line
the rook has to take on b1
and then the line is this
this and then this
some pretty high level stuff going on
here i guess there's also 91.
hmm so the point of this is to create
the pin
and then play f5 queen v6
takes takes
it doesn't make sense
it's really hard for white to get out of
the pin after it takes takes
because rook v2 is met with c3 c2
not playing particularly quickly eric is
still
killing it
of course i have to watch out for
discoveries but
maybe i don't get how producer pat's in
fifth place let's check out his game
also some position idea let's see what
pat's up to here
uh let's see if we can flip this
no we can't
oh here it is
okay producer pat on the bottom
pat playing against someone
significantly better rated now
let's even turn on the evaluation and
lines
uh hold on a second let's see
there we go
pat taking a lead best move here is g6
best move is capturing
oh it got flipped again
okay pat on the bottom again pat losing
oh my god
g5 apparently the best move
pat not playing it
queen to c7 or yeah queen c7 is
considered the best move
pat not playing
oh very very bad position for pat
should capture on d5 and he does
discovered
check
where does pat go from here
that's where he goes
hmm
looking very grim here for producer pat
now is the rook stuck basically
hmm
but pat's opponent playing some
unorthodox moves
oh not looking good
free bishop yeah
oh but now he gets it back
was not free after all
hmm pat thinking
does lose the night
that seemed like a major blunder
okay
this is an odd game
yeah i like that people are finally
allowed to say merry christmas again i
know because for so long you just
weren't allowed it was crazy
we're also looking into sinks and
showers really strongly
elements of bathrooms
elements of medical
wow producer pat cleaning it up but
still minus 12
according to the engine
which is pretty tough
thanks to hellstorm angel for the twitch
prime subscription as we are in the last
three minutes of the tournament we will
see what happens pat's queen is very
very powerfully under attack
this game becoming a bit of a mess and
let's go over and see what's going on
with eric rosen
i have an idea
i offer to draw
because otherwise the game doesn't count
for the tournament
uh oh eric's trying to figure out a way
to get a point
and my queen is trapped
right because eric's down a point now
what is my opponent going to do
now if he draws he would get one point
right is that the strategy uh
that doesn't really benefit me
i guess i'll play knight g4
alright g5 hitting the queen again
there is a minute left in the tournament
one minute left
how do i create tricks here
or t1
like 81.
the takes i take here that's still
interesting down to the last 49 seconds
my queen is still trapped though
this move
well this is a sticky position here
wow
again the tournament's going to end the
game's going to be aborted if we don't
agree to a draw
27
i don't think my opponent knows that
though
hmm
20. okay this is my last chance draw
let's see what happens
otherwise i'll just let the game all
aboard
okay well good job mr kusha
winning a clutch game in the end
wow
and there it is ladies and gentlemen it
is over
in first place mr kusha chess twitch
with 49 points
in second place
eric rosen
and in third place do nice lord with 388
players
somehow producer pat
getting seventh place winning
14.5 out of 24 possible points based on
the games that he played
the participation is what matters that
is exactly right
that is exactly right
i had my hopes high
but then my hopes were
crushed
right
also rambo is wrong it's over now it is
over it is completely and totally over
thank you to everybody who played
very often in every tournament i've done
one of the top three ends up being
booted for cheating once the chess.com
algorithm catches them hopefully that
doesn't happen today with anybody who's
in the top three
i appreciate everybody joining me
we will have the trump rally stream on
saturday and we will have other streams
in the intervening time good game
everybody
we did it and we will see everybody
very very
soon you